foreign
and thanks to all of you for joining us
here and those of us who are joining us
remotely
um I hope it's going to be interesting
we have got a stellar panel here to
explore the question of can the UK
become a science superpower
um on my immediate right my left your
right uh Daniel korski CEO of public uh
former special advisor David Cameron I
understand in on these sorts of issues
and um public is a venture capital firm
uh focused on helping technology
startups transform Public Services
next we have Smart Walpole former Chief
government science advisor uh so he
knows a fair amount about how
politicians think about science and I'm
hoping he will share some of those
secrets with us before that he was head
of the ukri which is the body that
decides how to distribute our r d budget
to the right kind of scientists in the
right way and last but not least at all
Zoe McDougall from Oxford nanopore now
if you haven't heard of their nanopore
make scalable DNA and RNA sequencing
devices for research by defense water
testing agriculture all sorts of bits
and you name it pretty much before we
delve into this question though I
thought we'd just take a quick listen to
any Chancellor Jeremy Hunt what he had
to say in his budget speech on Thursday
about the UK's its Science and
Technology position
I want to combine our technology and
science Brilliance with our formidable
Financial Services to turn Britain into
the world's next Silicon Valley I want
to go further so today I protect our
entire research budgets and confirm that
we'll increase Public Funding for r e to
20 billion by 24.25 as part of our
mission to make the United Kingdom a
science superpower
we'll get into the wording of that
statement in a second because it's
slightly misleading in my opinion but
we'll discuss that further but I thought
I'd just start by asking all of you guys
starting with you Dad
can the UK become a science superpower
or is it already
I think it's fair to say if we've got to
stick to the language of international
politics that we may not be a superpower
but we're sort of a rising power you
know we've got a lot of the basics right
we've got lots of great companies
nanopore is of course one fantastic
example we've got a big uh investment
sector that's willing to pour money into
it but the truth is also we haven't
quite done all the things that we need
to do in order to build up our arsenal
we haven't been spending enough on R D
we don't have enough people studying
various stem subjects and frankly
funding isn't really what it is in the
us if we had to compare ourselves so we
can get there but there's still work to
be done and the budget we've seen has
taken some steps forward and a few steps
backwards so we'll see over the next
coming period Well science superpower
well I mean the first thing is it's good
news that that is a government aim it's
really important and it really matters
for the future of the country because
we're going through an industrial
revolution amazing new technologies
amazing new businesses and we've got all
the challenges of climate demographic
change so we need to be
um we're extraordinarily good at
research there's no question about that
do we exploit it most effectively
probably not yet and the money is really
important but also the environment in
which researchers and innovators work
that's really important you know can we
continue to bring the best people from
overseas that's a really important test
so I think you know it's it's all good
news but there is a huge amount to do
yeah I want to get into the money and
those other issues in just a second Zoe
superpower or not
uh we are the center of some of the most
extraordinary science and Innovation and
I think we can talk about Academia but
we can also talk about industrial r d
which is a huge focus in this country
and we are amazing at spin outs and
you've obviously funded many of them but
we're not so good at scale up and the
life sciences industrial strategy that
was published about three years ago said
we the UK should have in the next few
years at least four com four companies
worth 20 billion pounds we're not quite
there yet our scale-up Ambitions really
have to be bigger as a country
now I thought I'd stay with you Zoe
because one area where we I think
certainly during the pandemic we
demonstrated the UK does lead in human
genomics getting information out of our
genes using them for the good of
medicine or Humanity at large your
company makes very clever devices that
do that I thought just by a way of
introducing nanopore and what you do
could you just talk us through what you
make of course
um so we developed we were spun out of
the University of Oxford in 2005 and
over the subsequent years we made a
molecular sensing platform it's really
based on electronics I've got one of our
devices here and while it can look at
lots of molecules proteins DNA our first
application is DNA sequencing and the
magic happens in here we have bespoke
electronics and attached to those
visible electronics are nanopores on a
membrane we essentially suck DNA through
very small holes and run an ionic
current through those holes and every
little Pico amp and fluctuation in that
current we we analyze it we translate
the signal into a DNA sequence so a few
of me for all the technical language but
basically what that means is DNA is in
every living thing humans plants animals
pathogens as we know through covid if
you know the DNA sequence you can
understand what the identity of that
organism is you can understand whether
it's healthy disease is it changing so
it's incredibly important information as
you said in the introduction around
Healthcare agriculture food safety all
sorts of amazing real world applications
and it's really the real world
applications that we're interested in
fantastic so those of you watching the
live stream will have got a good look at
that but the audience hasn't so Zoe
would you mind passing it round now as I
understand there's about 400 million
pounds worth of r d in that device so
it's not to leave this room
it can sequence your DNA so if you do
take it we know who you are we know who
your parents are and we know who your
kids are as well so you're not you're
not going to get away with it although
we only charge a thousand dollars for
for a starter pack so to be honest you
can shoplift it that's fine with us
available all good car phone Warehouse
maybe okay great so you let's have a
look at that
um but let's get stuck into this
question of funding the government has
protected the r d budget Jeremy Hunt
there in the comments saying he'd raised
it by 20 billion dollars 20 billion
pounds sorry in fact that was the
pre-existing commitment they maintained
science funding but this is in effect a
doubling of where we were before so are
we spending off I thought I'd start with
you mark
um well I mean you know what's the right
amount to spend on research and
development we are if you look at it as
a percentage of uh GDP we're still not
in the Forefront so we are perhaps about
2.4 at the moment if you take into
account the recent ons calculations
U.S Germany Korea were at three percent
in 2020. so it's good it's heading in
the right direction but it doesn't put
us by any means amongst the world
leaders
for you how important is that you are a
company that spies of Oxford University
that's showing that seed money that
early r d public spend must be crucial
if we're going to see better companies
better ideas come out of UK right yes it
really is and we were spawn out of
original ideas at the University of
Oxford actually we have collaborations
with 25 universities all over the world
and many of those are in the UK and we
actually sponsor research and
development in UK universities so that
when those incredibly amazing Blue Sky
ideas come out of the universities we
can then take the onward research and
onward development to make them into
product that then we have to face the
really practical elements of
manufacturing shipping around the world
supporting our customers and all of
those elements are continuing that we
need to focus on all the areas of them
and from your perspective in terms of
the companies they're growing do you get
the sense that we could be doing better
yeah just to add a couple of things to
what Mark has been saying um we're not
doing as well as some of our competitors
um but just to unpack that that's both
on the public sector side of the
spending but it's also private sector r
d spending isn't as high as some of our
competitors and the other thing to
remember is we have a very concentrated
expenditure profile so lots of things
are going on in the sort of Golden
Triangle of Oxbridge and London but not
as much outside compared to the much
more decentralized funding that we see
in lots of other countries and then
obviously by definition changes a little
bit the profile of what's coming through
now um there are lots of great
researchers they are producing lots of
great things but our University sector I
would argue isn't quite as good as
comparable sectors say in the US at
supporting companies to emerge and if we
compare some of our universities say to
the mits and the stanfords I'd argue
that we still have lots to learn to help
companies out
I agree with that but I mean if you look
at University sector it is an
extraordinarily powerful sector actually
you're maybe second of the world for the
us but it's hard to think of anywhere
else that has such an extraordinary
range of universities and I think I just
might not make a comment about what we
just seen from Zoe which is
there's a real convergence of
Technologies in that box so that's about
biology it's about chemistry it's about
engineering microfluidics all sorts of
Science and Engineering Technologies
gone into that and I think the other
thing to recognize is that when we talk
about science this actually we also need
to ask the humanities design
we need the whole package and that's
really important I think
so the question that brings us my mind
is so what's what's I think what's
acknowledged is we have a very powerful
r d engine you know the universities do
very well given we're not funding them
half as well literally half as well as
some other country I think Israel spends
10 of its uh
um GDP on on Research
but then that's not necessarily turning
into those companies that are really
driving the economy forward what what
needs to happen to bridge that Gap but I
mean Israel is actually a very
interesting example if I made because
Israel the r d expenditure is almost all
in industry and of course it's very
driven by the defense sector as well and
there's a really important point in that
which is the customer function really
matters and I think that's one of the
challenges in the UK which is it's all
very well making things but companies
will only come here if they can see a
market as well and so you know I've
worked for many years with and for the
NHS the NHS has got great regulation
it's got things like nice so it's
admired as a regulator but it's been
quite slow historically at incorporating
and being a purchaser of innovative
products but just to expand that what do
you need to succeed you need great
people you need money and you need
markets and what Mark is talking about
is one particular Market we're very
proud of the healthcare Market but you
could expand that out to say the public
sector more broadly you know we spent a
lot of money on defense and Welfare and
we have not seen the state kind of take
the role that we've seen in many other
countries U.S as well
um as a driver as a as a purchaser a
first effort
um so that's a problem then on people
you know the good news is we have
probably over the last 10 years of of
our burgeoning technology ecosystem you
know developed a mass of some 50 60 70
000 mid level uh people who can really
kind of bring the experience of fast
growing companies to to that next
generation of firms but it's not enough
and though we have a very generous
immigration system the question is the
extent to which lots of other things
that are going on
um are whether that's making the UK
sufficiently attractive to people it's
it's all fine and well if you as a
researcher can come to this country but
if you're slightly worried whether your
husband
um is going to be able to get a job or
get the right Visa um it may mean that
you'll decide to go somewhere else and
then finally on funding you'll quite
right to say that we have a great track
record of supporting early stage
companies you're making that point and
that we haven't quite been there to
support the latest stage and people tend
to go overseas the U.S in particular for
that kind of funding Gap but what we're
seeing recently is even early stage
funding has taken a downward turn right
uh so we we mustn't be resting on our
Laurels even for early stage funding
so also in the comments Jeremy Hunt uh
described us as being the world or he
wanted to speak of the world's next
Silicon Valley I mean possibly not the
best analogy to draw given what we're
seeing going on in Silicon Valley at the
moment with Twitter's woes and meta
having to lay off 13 000 people but I
think we get his idea Zoe that's a is
that a cultural question and what do you
see as a business that has managed to
grow successfully in the UK Science and
Technology business what do you say
about the culture it's such an important
point so we have grown we are now a
thousand people we sell in 120 markets
we ipo'd last year in London and we saw
that as sort of Foothills of where we're
going but all the way through we have
faced not only our detractors but
actually our friends as well in many
cases telling us what we can't do and we
keep a list so we've been told we can't
make nanopore sequencing work we can't
make it good we can't manufacture it we
can't sell it especially not in the US
we've been told that we can't raise
money especially not in the US and we
were told that we can't IPO certainly
not in the UK and that we are too small
to be a collaborative partner to
Partners like the NHS now all of those
things are things that we have done but
we've done so often in spite of the help
that we've got so there is a really
cultural expectation we would like to
see a culture in the UK where all of
those Ambitions are recognized as
completely normal and we've been very
transparent with all of our stakeholders
whether they are investors or employees
or customers about these long-term
Ambitions but we would like to see more
people just feeling inspired and really
gung-ho about what they want to achieve
so with a cup half full I mean look at
so nanopore is a great example for
nanopore but look at deepmind that is
quite extraordinary you know that is
undoubtedly one of the most Cutting Edge
I'm proud to say they are deep owner
represented uh here later today so
they are doing extraordinary things we
are near a so-called silicon roundabout
here we've got a very strong satellite
industry so I mean there are areas where
we are extraordinarily strong but I mean
I would say both in the case of Oxford
nanopore and Deep Mind the founders have
had a very strong Vision that they want
to stay in the UK and there will have
been a plenty of voices telling them is
that he should go overboard abroad
it's now part of Google but nevertheless
they are very firmly based at King's
cross next to the Francis Crick
Institute we have a it raises another
question I think which is the importance
of clusters yeah you know Innovative
companies like to work near other
Innovative companies
and that's really important and with and
we're seeing that around King's cross
we're seeing that to some extent in East
London we're seeing it in other parts of
the country there's a Compound
Semiconductor
to follow up on your important points
about trying to distribute some of this
idea and this knowledge economy across
the UK world and have it centered around
obstin Cambridge but before we do just
on that cultural question you work in
money you're a venture capitalist I mean
do we have the right attitude in the UK
look I think we have to be careful not
to think that there's only one way of
being a great entrepreneur and it's uh
you know the sort of Elon Musk way and
we all have to be like him and look like
him and say the things that he does I'm
not even sure that's working
particularly well for him but um so we
have to be careful we don't kind of
create a stereotype entrepreneurs great
Founders come in all shapes and sizes
there's two scientists and researchers
but I think it is true to say that we
can be a bit and I say this with a with
the accent of a of a of a new Brit
um you know we can be a bit sort of um
self-contained in our in our in our
expression you know oh are you really
sure you're going to do that so we we
definitely need a little bit of a boost
and I do think government plays an
enormously important role in kind of
setting that high bar support those who
want to go far you know casting a light
on those who are who are struggling but
have that big vision and achievement
even at the risk that some of them
aren't going to succeed to the extent
that we hope for
you have to then wrap that cultural
Point down to the sort of realities of
well hang on where are you going to get
the money from where are you going to
get the people from what are you going
to do if you want to list at the very
end and if it's very difficult to list
in the UK or at least not as attractive
as elsewhere then culture is only going
to get you so far at the end of the day
there's got to be some some destination
you're aiming for
if we are trying to sort of drive a new
Industrial Revolution here as it's often
described and
how do we make that more Equitable
across the UK I mean the the government
previous governments as well have looked
at clusters at catapults at places where
we can accelerate and provide
opportunities for companies are those
working could we do it better
I mean the answer is if you look across
the UK there are areas of great strength
distribution widely across the country
you look across Southern Scotland
there's incredible Quantum Technologies
photonics Quantum Technologies yeah
Quantum Quantum Computing and yeah and
satellite industry as well you look in
the Midlands there's the Warwick there's
Advanced manufacturing center there are
real areas of strength um uh renewable
energy Northeast for example so when you
draw the map you do actually see why
they distribute strengths I think the
mistake is to think that you can
suddenly dump as it were a
nanotechnology Institute in any part of
the country what you have to do is build
on strengths and we've got great
universities very widely distributed
they all have enormous areas of strength
and the best universities have areas of
weakness as well so I think the trick is
not as it were just to try and create
something out of the blue because that's
very difficult but to work out where the
areas of strengths are and build up you
know Manchester a great University lots
of strengths it's where
um
I think carbon graphene wouldn't come
out you're right
just examples like that we just have to
build on them wherever they are now
there's it's interesting you mentioned
graphic because as far as my reporting
on this particular area went to film
with a graphene-based company they're
trying to use graphene to make
microchips effectively to try and
replace uh the existing semiconductors
with graphene as the conductor
potential makes them a thousand times
more energy efficient potentially a
thousand times more powerful yet the
owner of that company saying I might
have to leave the UK because I've got
nowhere to expand the supply chain isn't
there and there are challenges facing
the growth he's well funded he's got
good money he's got contracts it's can
he grow his business in the UK as his
concern
look I'll come back to you but just to
pick up on Mark's point which is um
there's a tendency to say what you need
here are clusters and then to approach
that in a very sort of artificial way
but what is really at the heart of a
cluster why does a cluster work because
it's a network it's a network of people
who have some level of commonality or
insight into what each other are doing
and so forth and if you look at almost
anything that's been successful in this
country or anywhere else over a long
period two things tend to emerge right
very strong networks of stakeholders who
manage to work together across various
different organizational divides and
then kind of long-term commitment to
whatever it is that they're trying to
achieve and I think in this country we
can do better on both on the first we
can do better at ensuring that the right
people are connected across the country
if you look at the way that we support
most Innovation we do it through r d tax
credits and r d tax credits um are both
an incredibly effective means but also
quite an obscure one you don't really
know who's been given an r d tax credit
you might want to collaborate with them
can't quite find that out so there are
other things you can do in order to make
it easier for people the network within
or across geographical clusters and then
there's this long-terminism which we
haven't touched upon the commander of
the 82nd Airborne a very famous U.S
military unit once told me that the most
important thing for anything he did was
stick-to-itiveness
and I like that and I think we need to
stick to it of this in this country if
we want to achieve things right sorry I
want to ask you what allowed nanopore to
grow to a large company before I do I
just wanted to remind everyone in the
audience if you have questions the QR
code on your cards uh and those of us
those of you following the live stream
questions via Twitter we're hoping it
keeps operating throughout the day but
yeah so just coming back to you
um
you your nanopore managed to grow
how important was the association with
Oxford did you benefit from that
location and did that money come
exclusive from the UK I mean help me
understand the story well we're
headquartered in the UK but we have a
very International Outlook and actually
all of our shareholders are from from
the UK but from Asia from North America
from all over the world and I think we
shouldn't confuse UK companies selling
to UK audience and having UK investors
with companies that make their home in
the UK
um so I think that's one important thing
and then something you said has
stimulated me to think about the power
of community and tearing down barriers
to Innovation so one of our critical
points was when we first released our
product and you've gone around there
somewhere it's still here so we made it
I'm still going around okay sorry so we
made a choice we had an Electronics
platform we could have made a million
pound box which is what all the other
people in our sector do and sold it to
the five most important geneticists in
the world and said right let's do this
thing but we didn't we chose to make a
very small accessible device easy to
make easy to ship to customers in FedEx
and we said we want to make it as
accessible as possible see what you can
do with it so we are a platform but we
are just the start of the Innovation
pathway and we have people in LA London
at geisens and Thomas's developing
amazing workflows on respiratory
metagenomics so basically by the end of
the ward round understanding what
pathogens you have present in a long
sample but you have people in Sierra
Leone doing agricultural work using
genomics so for us we're just the start
of that Innovation pathway and we cannot
do it without not only UK but Global
collaborations and we really do feel
privileged to be part of the solution
with the people who are developing new
uses for our technology and that's what
helped us grow we we co-create as much
as possible
I think that brings us squarely on to an
important question in all of this we've
just gone through a bit of an upheaval
when it comes to our relationship with
the rest of the world
um in terms of science funding a lot of
that used to come through the Horizon
program you don't know that that's the
European Union's big Grant scheme that
Britain used to benefit from quite
disproportionately as a as a function of
the amount of money we put in that money
is obviously guaranteed to be uh made up
for by the government but there's a lot
of research relationships as I
understand it there have been damaged by
that we've also got questions about the
movement of people we used to obviously
work quite freely with scientists and
the engineers across Europe uh that's
taken a bit of a hit and I'm also
hearing the trade deals that we were
looking to sort of Step In
there's a few questions around them I
don't want to mention the b word but for
exit what's the impact been on doing
science in the UK but also on our
prospects for continuing to thrive in a
global economy
well I mean if I can start with people
because
one of the things about Oxford is it
change educates brilliant people if you
look around Cambridge where there's a
very big cluster yeah most of that
cluster isn't actually spin-outs from
the University it's people from the
University and those people have come
from all over the world with a
substantial member who've come from
Europe because they were all the schemes
you're watching at Sky News it's 11
o'clock we're going to take you back now
to our special event Big Ideas live and
they're asking the question who owns the
future that's one of the reasons that
our University sector or our higher
education or further education sector is
so important and it's not only the the
the the the the the the primary research
innovators it's all the technical stuff
that support the incredibly
sophisticated infrastructure and you
know the evidence is that there is less
Mobility uh to and from Europe the rest
of Europe to the UK
um this really matters ultimately I mean
we have got to part of being a we're
we're in a global market that's the
point
the best researchers innovators will go
anywhere in the world and there's pretty
sophisticated and expensive Market
actually so you know we've got to make
sure that we remain an attractive place
for people to come and work and of
course that housing costs salaries
education all of that matters
um and I think that you know the UK's
got to work out its place in the world
but make sure as part of it that we are
really open to talent and there are 10
visas but you at the end of the day it's
a market and we'll see what people do
are we less attractive now though I mean
I I think it is probably undoubtedly the
case that it has become harder to come
from Europe to the UK but at the same
time a successive governments have have
created an immigration system targeting
you know talented people entrepreneurs
that is probably one of the most um
liberal of anywhere else certainly
compared to our competitors and so we
are also attracting and continue to
attract great talent more globally and
Mark's of course entirely right you
can't rest on that alone and we've got
to tell a story and that story has to do
with lots more than the job that you can
get here but I I'm I'm enormously
optimistic and because this is still a
great place to come and build and create
a business
um we have some great cities some great
universities but people also come follow
all sorts of other reasons you know
great football and uh good culture and
you must forget these people don't just
look for
um the the company they want to work at
right they look at a much bigger picture
so we have every reason to believe that
we can tell a great story I think the
interesting question you haven't touched
on yet is you know the chancellor said
we're in a recession you know what's
that going to do a lot of the things
that we've talked about has been about
spending money
um well not just by the state but also
by others what happens when a recession
begins cutting budgets and they're sort
of two ways of thinking about that you
can either be worried or you can look at
you know past recessions where almost
every recession is seen the emergency
was really fantastic companies and there
may be less funding for everything but
that may also mean that there's more
funding for the really exciting more
serious bets and a lot of the sort of
more frivolous things that have been
funded over the years getting a pizza to
you faster or a different colored
t-shirt you know that you can buy
through Tick Tock may get less funding
and probably a good thing too
yeah yeah
do you want to uh any I mean any direct
impacts on your business is this
something that you're concerned about
with that question about recession well
I think you guys are covered really all
those Salient points I think the only
thing I could possibly add is the joy
among the uh the tech bio sector when
Twitter and meta started announcing that
they were letting their machine learning
people go gosh I mean I've never seen so
many CEO LinkedIn posts saying come and
work for a place where instead of
checking out a pizza the point that you
were making earlier your machine
learning skills can be put to big data
sets around genomics or around Imaging
or anything else where your your day job
can be really making a difference and so
I think that's a redistribution of
talent that we're actually very excited
about in our sector but but I mean so I
think the challenge is just for the uh
politicians to make it absolutely clear
that the UK is a place that people can
come and live work and play if they're
going to be recruited to the very best
companies
and be rewarded for it personally which
is an issue of income tax but also
corporately which is um which is why
it's really pleasing to see the
government hang on to some of the early
stage uh tax incentives that the
previous government introduced we've got
to make it easy for people to put money
into those early stage businesses it's
good you brought us back to the
government because I had another
question about this
um
obviously Jeremy Hunt sounded like many
other chances before him saying I want
to put a high-tech sector or you know
Aerospace or biotechnology at the center
of the UK economy every government wants
to be bullied yet hardly any politicians
are scientists I think I saw a statistic
and I may be getting this wrong I think
it was something less than 15 of cabinet
level politicians have a science degree
compared to about 46 of graduates across
the UK uh on average and that if the
politicians don't get science and the
Civil Service doesn't really get it we
need more talent in politics but what do
you say to that well I mean this the
short answer is you can't blame the
people who stand for politics you can
only blame the people that don't stand
and I think one of the real challenges
for scientists engineers technologists
is that you go to university and it's
almost treated as a vocational education
and the idea that you might go into sort
of politics or some kind of public
service is not part of it and so I think
it does go back to education as I say
the only way you'll fix the problem in
politics is to get more scientists
engineers Etc to stand for election if
they won't
um what can you do about it so as I say
it's very hard to blame the existing
politicians they've they've they've
stood
um but I do think it's a problem that if
you like the if you look at the future
science engineering technology the Arts
design are so intrinsic to it
that we have to make sure that those
people contribute to all walks of life
and so I think it's an educational issue
as much as anything you did your time in
number 10 what was that were you well by
saying I wonder whether Mark paid you to
sort of ask them whether everybody else
should be like Mark Walpole um professor
of science but but uh no more is that
correct but more seriously more
seriously um
it is not just the question of who
stands for office it is also a question
of who engages in the public sphere
because you can influence and affect uh
you know the ship of State in lots of
different ways and the good news is that
coming out of the pandemic I think the
whole nation the whole world knows how
important science is
um you know Mark when you were the chief
scientist uh in government I doubt most
people knew who you were no disrespect
but simply you know you hadn't had the
platform to talk to people in the way
that your successor has had because he
had to go on uh you know TV all the time
you know Mark had his moments I I
definitely recall but yeah I know I I
think we get what you're saying the
point is simply that the people realize
the importance of Science and its role
in public policy making and so you're
right to say we need more people
standing for office but I would argue
that we need something much broader
which is people who understand and know
these subjects need to spend more time
involved in shaping public policy I I
agree with that but again I think if you
look at the American University system
you'll find far more Masters courses
that are devoted to for example helping
scientists and researchers to become
involved in public policy so I think it
does come back to being an educational
Point although I agree with you and the
other point I'd make is actually there
are an enormous number of scientists
engineering Technologies working for
government but they tend to be working
in the back rooms that's the point I
mean the thing I discovered when I
started the government Chief Scientific
Advisor was the enormous number of
people who basically work fairly quietly
at keeping us safe and many of those
people are working in science
engineering and Technology can I just
make one point which is around diversity
which is um it is great that we have so
many people coming into the Sciences at
education I mean but we need more and
the truth is we also need a much more
diverse cohort in all sorts of ways
whether that's ethnic Regional gender or
whatnot and I think we we see some great
efforts to make a difference but I think
we we need to up our game but if I can
comment on that because one of the
things I do is I chair the Kennedy
Memorial trust which was set up to as
Memorial to JFK after he was
assassinated we send about 10 people to
have an MIT each year typically to do
the sort of Masters in public policy
public administration the diversity of
that group is now extraordinary and so
the access schemes to universities it's
beginning to work but you're right I
mean this has got to change but I think
it is beginning to great news I think
what we're talking about sorry sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt you I was going
to say we're talking about Talent here
um
could we nurture that Talent better in
the UK I believe compared to some of our
International uh equivalents we do quite
well at training scientists and
engineers in the UK
could we train them better could we
train different types of scientists and
engineers and I think Zoe I call each of
you in terms of who you're recruiting
where those smart brains are coming from
the type of people you need and where
they're coming from and whether they're
equipped to enter companies like yours
and we see an enormous shortage of of
stem trained undergraduates but to your
point it's a real lack of diversity our
engineering team is desperate to hire
people with more sort of the team
themselves say look we are mainly you
know fantastic white men we want more
diversity of thought we want more
creativity in our team and actually what
we're starting to do now is try to take
our technology into the school into high
schools into undergraduates into medical
schools and try and bring that sort of
inspiration about science because
talking about sequencing you're not just
talking about biology or talking about
experimental design you'll talk about
engineering you'll talk about data
analysis or talking about communication
you're talking about policy ethics there
are so many ways to bring these skills
earlier so that you are more people
feeling more included by the science
journey through education I completely
agree with you Mark we can get more
people more educated get more kinds of
creativity into that Innovation Journey
if I could just add to that and it goes
a bit to the point I think Mark you were
making earlier which is so much
Innovation is happening on the cusps of
different discipline and we have I think
in the University sector been quite good
at bringing various different
disciplines together we could probably
be better but I think there's a there's
a sort of another element is are we good
enough at allowing scientists to spend a
little bit of time in the pockets of
policy makers and corporates and so on
as part of their scientific education
and in my experience the answer is no
people tend to stay in their silos and
if they collaborate they might do so
with another University department but
they're unlikely to do so with a
corporate or with a government body and
that I think to me is something we ought
to be thinking a bit about I agree with
that completely Daniel I think that the
financial incentives uh in the
University sector don't make it easy for
people to move around in that way and I
agree with you I think I think it's
another issue in it it's not only Early
Education it's actually people in
postdocs many of whom will not go on to
be research leaders in universities
there isn't I think enough emphasis on
Skilling them for all the the different
opportunities as there are and you know
frankly if you are a scientist and you
are inquisitive you know how to ask
experiments you understand statistics
and you you have to be a good
communicator those are the skills for
almost every Walk of Life
we're going to go some questions in just
a minute but before we do I'm going to
throw a curveball at all of you the
question we're posing oh it's not on the
screen anymore but
the name of this whole uh event is who
owns the future and I thought I'd put
that to it just a quick thought if you
could certainly perhaps starting with
you we've got such a firm opinion on
this so you have challenges across the
world that genomics can answer it's
health challenges it's environmental
challenges food security challenges 30
of the food that is produced goes to
waste because of pathogens and pests in
the world extraordinary
and those problems are experienced by
the people who are not where the
Innovation is happening so we want to
make our technology we want to tear down
those barriers so the people who have
the challenges are the people who are
creating the solutions for those
problems so I guess our answer to that
was we think the future belongs to the
people with the problems to solve so
that they can drive the solving of those
problems thank you I'd give a slightly
different answer which is that I think
it's the youngest people in the room who
own the future and we all in the future
for future Generations and I think
that's one of the big challenges that
we're seeing the challenge at the cop
meeting in Cairo at the moment uh we own
the future of our own species on the
planet and also for the others with
which we share the planet
um and so I think it's why I'm afraid I
keep coming back to the fact that we're
not going to be able to cope that we've
just crossed that gather the eight
billion humans on the planet of Andrew
we're heading probably 10 billion
something like that you look at the
waste we're producing invisible waste in
terms of carbon emissions visible in
terms of the sort of muck that's
contaminating rivers and the seas around
the world uh if we don't if it is us
that owns it and it's it's the young
people who are going to have the most
um impact
um and and if we care about future
generations and I think that's one of
the challenges that research shows we
care about our children we care about
our grandchildren we can imagine them if
you ask people how much they care about
their grandchildren's grandchildren not
enough is the answer yeah so it's our
role to skill those future generations
to tackle those challenges I I would say
this because I'm the Science and
Technology editor but I think it sounds
a technology that's probably the answer
to many of those questions social
sciences matter too and the social
sciences that's not that's every body
and those designers in the artist too
Daniel but just at the risk of giving uh
the same answer with slight variation I
mean you own the future in the sense
that it has never been easier than today
to define a problem and build Solutions
attract people to help you money to
support you and and access the
architecture you need to build something
whether that's a software architecture
or or more physical architecture and
then access markets immediately Beyond
you or further field it has never been
easier never been easier so the future
belongs to you but the great news is
that you have the the levers at your
disposal to do something about it in a
way no previous generation had as easily
fantastic thanks very much indeed right
so we promised there would be questions
that we're going to go to them right now
we have some minutes for that I've got
one here in the audience
uh
hero uh
Hiro are you out there uh there's your
hand fantastic could you just pause a
moment for the microphone to come
towards you and I believe it's got
something to do with brexit which is
perhaps predictable please could you
stand up Sir so uh we can see you and
there's a microphone above your head so
you should we should be able to hear
your question
um
yeah
um
you know we've got greater opportunities
[Music]
thanks very much for that here so if you
didn't make that out there's a question
about brexit has it has it hindered us
or are there post brexit opportunities I
mean certainly the chances both done
maybe he had to but are there are there
some opportunities that we can leverage
now that we've left the EU anyone have a
crack well speaking of someone who
argued for our stay inside the EU I'm
going to take the position then I think
we can we can focus too much on the
negative aspects here large parts of
what we do particularly in the
technology sector as opposed to the
science sector you know was not
regulated inside the EU single Market
anyway and so a lot of people who are
selling various
um uh cloud-based services in the in the
EU and 2D rather you know have not been
affected it would of course be
um Preposterous to argue that it has had
no impact the obr has been pretty clear
that there has been an economic impact
and as a as a result of that that will
influence lots of sectors including ours
but I think that we can be too negative
about
um the impact and I I see in lots of
sectors that it it hasn't been as
disadvantageous as I think a lot of
people feared indeed that I feared
myself so I'm going to be more
optimistic about the situation we find
ourselves in okay I mean I think it's
too early to know to be honest I mean
one of the big challenges is that the UK
has made it clear uh that it wants to
participate in Horizon Europe but
Horizon Europe has actually been held
hostage in Europe to the solution of the
Northern Ireland protocol
um so there's a lot of uncertainty still
I think the other thing is that a lot
has been made about the opportunity of
regulatory Freedom yes and that is true
but
um that regulation and science is often
abused to create trade barriers and so
there's no use regulating something
completely different to the rest of the
world if the rest of the world then says
it went by the product
and I think that's one of the challenges
actually which is that the amount of
regulatory Divergence may be limited by
the need to actually sell one's product
into other markets right I mean it's
interesting one of the the brexit
freedom cybers of media aware of was
biotechnology so Gene editing of course
well that's a good example that was knee
regulation that was holding uh UK
Innovation back but as soon as those
products now start to emerge the EU is
very rapidly revising its regulations
because I think they've recognized maybe
the Market's there and actually the
advantage may have slightly vanished but
possibly gave us a bit of a head start
yeah
sorry any thoughts on that I mean I
think it's it's a small world now kovid
showed us that we can all collaborate
with people online on zoom and they can
have a lab in Oxford collaborating with
a lab in Singapore in real time on Zoom
I think you know Europe is incredibly
important to us as a country but it's
not the only region with which we can
collaborate and make new innovation and
and sell products as well so it's
something we just work through put our
tin hats on and make sure we make the
best of the situation fantastic so I'm
going to take a question from Twitter
now this is for from Sir mattington on
Twitter the question is why does the UK
not expand our domestic chip industry
fabrication plants for example Taiwan
leads the way at the moment and surely
it would create jobs is there a barrier
that prevents us from doing this I mean
we talked about Silicon Valley it's very
excited not chips not for me but it's an
example I think though of a
manufacturing infrastructure of a
history of a certain uh industry
it was in the news recently because the
government decided to protect one of our
few remaining chip manufacturing plants
um yeah is that the sort of thing we
need to be concentrating on
um okay well we are a world leader in
making compound semiconductors which
amongst the most sophisticated and that
that's really all here Mark sorry I can
just detect can you hear mark saying in
the audience you can't carry on sorry to
interrupt so we do have a a a a a a chip
industry and it's a very high-end one I
think the problem is that the cost of a
chip factory is absolutely massive and
so the cost of capital for getting
started here is huge
um I mean the Americans realize there's
an issue because of the great dependency
on Taiwan the chip manufacture and that
is a one of you know one of the things I
think uh Ukraine war has made people
suddenly aware of is the huge grow
Global interdependency on uh resources
and governments probably haven't paid
enough attention I mean worldwide to the
security of suppliers the products that
they take for granted you know raw
minerals all the three way through but I
mean it is a at some level it's a it's a
quite a complicated question which is
who is going to provide the investment
to make AK trip Factory which we're
talking many billions and perhaps comes
back to your point from earlier about
let's concentrate on our strengths
rather than look for areas in which we
we can't lead in everything above our
weight sorry I mean I was simply going
to add
um that what we're seeing now to Mark's
point with governments waking up to the
challenge of the security of Supply
um a really interesting move so in the
US we have the chips act which has
basically stopped dead the Chinese Chips
industry immediately the extent to which
that's actually going to encourage
discourage War over the Taiwan Straits
we don't know but I think it speaks to a
point of um the need for government to
be you know have to have a large
long-term coherent you know plan yes the
uh the recent business secretary is this
decision over over the manufacturing
side in Wales you know is an element but
is it part of a larger coherent strategy
of where we want to play in the chip
supply chain I I'm not so sure I know
the answer to that and so I think if if
anything it isn't just a question where
do you want to play sexually but also
where in the supply chain do you want to
play where does the money come from and
what else are you willing to do you know
in order to attract people or stop other
people hiring you know britons to go
overseas in the way that the Americans
have it's kind of come together in a
little bit of a of a piece that involves
many stakeholders we're not quite there
and and of course we're very good at
chip designs as well so oh it's uh you
we've got to you know everyone who's got
a phone so we don't necessarily have to
have the manufacturing to benefit from
that part I think that brought a
question is one of resilience yeah in a
world where people had taken it for
granted you could just buy stuff off the
shelves yeah and then when that huge
tanker got stuck in this year's Canal we
were extraordinarily lucky that there
wasn't a disaster so that had been stuck
there for longer we'd have found all
sorts of Supply problems and I think the
important point to remember on that is
what is the trade-off we're willing to
accept do we want to pay more for things
will we allow things not to be so
instantaneous in order to be more secure
and I don't think we've quite had that
to be yeah great I'm just we've got time
for one more question in the audience
Dino are you out there do you know in
the background there you are oh I love
the shirt fantastic bring your Hawaiian
vibe to hoxton
um could you stand upset it just it
might help with the audio yes
but I think it's been sort of covered
about education but going back to the
beginning so uh I was actually recording
a podcast yesterday about early junior
high school education we talked about
joining the dots and arts and craft and
all those sorts of things have we got an
education system fit for the future
if not what would be your curriculum
what would you add
foreign
the problem with education is that
everyone has strong views because
everyone's either been to school or
knows someone who has been
um and the challenge is that the
education is a super tanker it's quite
difficult to steer and so everyone
always wants to change the curriculum
um I mean I I just think the important
thing is that people get a diversity of
Education I think one of the challenges
for the UK system is that we're one of
the most specialized at an early age
and so I personally I think it's
important that everyone does English and
maths until they leave school at
whatever age
um I think Arts education is incredibly
important
um and it's clearly important that you
know numerous is probably the most
important thing of all in some ways
because you close more doors in terms of
job opportunity if you are innumerate
than almost anything else and the
challenge is to get that throughout
education I think
entrepreneurialism not because I think
everybody's going to be a Founder but
because I think it teaches agency it
tells you you don't just have to go and
do what everybody else did before you
what your parents did what your friends
did you have the power to shape things
and create things and we're very bad at
teaching entrepreneurialism we're very
bad at bringing Founders and
entrepreneurs into schools just to tell
the kids what we're about we're very bad
at saying hey why don't you have a go if
you had to create a business you know
outside the Talk Shop what would you do
um which is very bad at doing that and
and as I say it's not because I think
everybody's going to be an entrepreneur
but it teaches agency and if you want to
come back to who owns the future and if
it's about you owning the future that's
about agency let's teach the kids you
know you need to know all these things
but you have the power the tools
to get there and solve some of these
problems fantastic
so it's such important points and
obviously there is a lot of innovation
happening in education and there is now
a trend away from calling it education
and towards calling it learning because
it's not just about the school curricula
it's about what happens on a Saturday
because you're going to entrepreneur cam
for it's what happens after you've left
school and there are so many ways to Art
skill and learn more and sort of expand
your horizons now that it's a really
really exciting place to be in education
thank you thank you very much all of you
for helping us explore that there's so
much more to get into so I have to cut
us off there uh thank you very much
again for exploring the question of
whether Britain is isn't or can be a
science superpower